for months Andrew Tate has been in
prison in Romania along with his brother
Tristan and two Romanian women the
controversial influencer is being
investigated over claims of human
trafficking rape and forming a criminal
gang to sexually exploit women they all
deny all the allegations court papers
say the Tate brothers are now under
house arrest for 30 days as they left
prison they pushed through crowds to a
car with darkened windows
[Applause]
on this Sky News Daily Neil looks at why
Andrew Tate still has so many loyal
supporters
I frost encountered the influencer
Andrew Tate many months ago on his brand
of hyper masculine misogyny began
appearing somewhat inexplicably on my
social media if you put a whole bunch of
men a whole bunch of women you strand
them on a desert island the men would
start having to build things and fight
off the animals and the women would
start farming and whatever the women
would do he's made his name preaching
his view of 21st century masculinity his
target audience those still trying to
work that out for themselves if as some
say the measure of a man is the Legacy
he leaves well Andrew Tate has already
left his Mark some would say stain on
society but I said that if a woman is
going out with a man she belongs to that
man that's his woman so she wants to do
only fans she owes him some money
because she's his and that's one of the
milder comments he's made much of his
content is simply too offensive to share
including discussion of hitting and
choking women and his suggestion that
sexual assault survivors share
responsibility for their attacks
billions of views later he remains
utterly unrepentant or perhaps simply
indifferent to the Abundant criticism I
want all the people who hate me and go
he's an misogynist to sit there broke
and I want all the people who go Tate's
a g to be flexing despite making his
fortune through a variety of online
activities Tate now finds himself
permanently banned from Facebook
Instagram YouTube and Tick Tock but his
content continues to circulate and so to
his reach the problem with that is
obvious that whilst once we said it took
a village to raise a child nowadays
anyone with the internet can directly
access and influence our kids
so who is Andrew Tate and how did he
emerge from the darkest corners of the
web to worldwide infamy
I'm Neil Patterson and this is the Sky
News Daily
later I'll be speaking to an online hate
expert who explained the remarkably tech
savvy strategy that resulted in Tate's
rise from obscurity to ubiquity and
explore the effects of his online
misogyny with a writer who's researched
male sexual entitlement
but first he's a British American
kickboxer the son of an international
chess master journalist Shanti Das who's
been digging into Andrew Tate's
background for the Observer he was
raised on an estate in Luton he sort of
first came to be known in public because
of his kickboxing career but then he
went on Big Brother in 2016 and from
then there was a couple of years where
he was sort of making headlines for
saying very controversial things
basically he was kicked off big brother
in 2016 over a video that surfaced in
which he allegedly attacked a woman he
claimed it wasn't abuse and it was
consensual and then over the next couple
of years there were various
controversies so in the wake of the
white Harvey Weinstein Scandal he said
women should take personal
responsibility for being raped and then
later he tweeted that depression isn't
real certainly he seems to portray
himself as a man of means there's lots
of evidence on on social media of well
at least there is some evidence of
exceptional riches yeah he's built up a
personality you know a profile on line
in which he sort of appears to portray a
very glamorous lifestyle say posing with
very fancy cars at his mansion in
Romania where he lives and posing with
wads of cash and lots of women very
glamorous or outward picking lifestyle I
mean certainly undertake himself has
suggested that part of the reason that
he has moved to Romania is the culture
there but but also the legal system so
he has said that you know one of the
reasons why he moved there is basically
it's harder to be held to account for
sexual abuse allegations and he said
that was 40 of the reason that he moved
there and he's also just talked about
how he he just thinks it's a Freer
Society he talked in the UK about how he
was being the best investigated by UK
police for several months there was also
I mean I believe this business is still
good ongoing something known as the the
Hustler's University over the last few
months in particular he has attracted
um more it was more than 120 000 fans to
horses University it's like an online
Academy where it's offering customers
particularly young men and boys an
opportunity to make money so people
signing up were told that there'd be the
opportunity they could earns or
thousands of pounds a month and there
are various strands and different types
of lessons that they'd be taught how to
do that so things like crypto investing
Drop Shipping and then a really big one
was in affiliate marketing scheme which
meant that
the more people you in the more sort of
other members they referred and the more
people that gets that they got signed up
they would get a commission that that
sounds I don't know how best to put this
kind of almost like a triangular
structure maybe a bit pyramidy
yeah so here's Denise claims that it's a
pyramid scheme um but he was uh
basically yes it relies very much on
people sharing content and getting other
people to sign up give us a few examples
of the kind of stuff that that Andrew
trade has been putting up and I'll
confess he came across my radar you know
a good few months ago just started
popping up on on lots of social Feats
and I couldn't quite believe when I was
hearing a lot of people over the last
few months have found that when they're
scrolling through social media feed and
particularly Tick Tock as I say they
were getting promoted lots and lots of
Andrew take content and the types of
views that he's expressing ranged from
things like saying women belong in the
home shouldn't go out without their
boyfriends didn't go on girls holidays
or a man's property can't drive to sort
of more extreme things so there's a
video where he describes throwing a
woman's things out of a window there's
other ones where he talks about
hypothetically what he'd do if he caught
a woman if a woman sort of accused him
of cheating and he says he it's bang out
the machete boom in her face and grab
her by the neck and you'll often uses
like derogatory terms towards women and
things like John ho and calling them
other really offensive words
as father to a boy aged six going on 16
I'll admit to a personal interest in
this story after all it is difficult
enough being a dad these days trying to
provide an example of what it means to
be a good man without those online
supporting your best efforts there's
this whole idea of being toxically
masculine is complete garbage and the
reason it's garbage is because it's a
first world problem indeed States would
be entirely easy to dismiss if he was
merely strong as an oak thick as two
short planks but it's his intelligence
and guile that brought him the fame and
the infamy well Andrew Tate realized
what many other people who want to make
themselves internet famous to try and
build some build some money off the back
of it have realized which is that
controversy sells on those platforms
because of the way they're constructed
Imran anit is chief executive of the
center for countering digital heat the
fundamental way to succeed on social
media is to produce controversial
content that gets people really angry
and he has produced that in spades so
explain then everyone why does such such
controversial content do so well I mean
it's a reflection of us it's a
reflection of the consumer isn't it well
yes and no to an extent it's of course a
reflection of billions and billions of
clicks that people have how long your
eyeballs rest on a video and these are
very sophisticated platforms that even
look at how long do you stay watching a
video before you move on okay give them
more of that but it's in part he says
himself you need to have lots of haters
who are following you too so who
produces content that creates reactions
engagement but it doesn't matter if it's
positive or negative platforms don't
care they just want to keep us on the
platform so in fact feeding us stuff
that we actually think is morally
repulsive can be as effective as feeding
us stuff which is interesting or factual
or actually makes us feel better about
the day
it all feels like you know another kind
of you know for one of a better phrase
decentralized Revenue stream for Android
even if he's not producing this content
he's he's still benefiting from it I
mean let's talk about the efforts to try
and and remove Andrew Tate from from the
mainstream platforms I mean freezing his
accounts in and of himself isn't isn't
going to do it it won't be sufficient on
its own and what we're going to have to
do in fact is is get to grips with
social media companies that that say
that they're taking action but actually
fail to do so with a simple change of
name of account or a tactic like Andrew
takes using where he's encouraging other
people to post his content and direct
them back to his business and I think
that you know that
social media companies have been a
little bit cutie about it all they they
always say two years after the event
they say oh we've taken action against
the main account but they know just as
well as I do that this is a standard
play tactic by Bad actors online so do
you see then Imran the platforms
themselves as complicit
in this misogyny
well yes and let me explain to you how
so let's take for example YouTube so
YouTube we've we did a small study where
we looked at the videos of Andrew Tate
on YouTube We calculated that for the
three most prominent accounts sharing
under a tate that YouTube was generating
3.4 million pounds in Revenue
that that doesn't sound like a ton of
money but let's not forget these
businesses are based off you know
hundreds millions of accounts which is
how you build up a billion dollar
Revenue company it's from these
components of 3.4 million and they've
been very reluctant in the past and
still are very reluctant with Andrew
take to take any action against accounts
sharing his content because in the end
it's revenues you've talked quite a bit
Imran about the intelligence that he's
clearly demonstrated the skills that he
has demonstrated the way in which he has
has gamed algorithms and all the rest of
it given that this is clearly he is
clearly not Daft he is clearly a smart
man I just wonder sometimes whether this
is all a bit performative or a bit of an
act well I don't know if he believes it
or not I can't tell what's in the hearts
of people but what I can tell you is the
effect of the content that he pushes out
into society which is that he keeps
telling young men that the way to be a
real man is to hurt women and to
dominate them to to subjugate them to
make them less than you and the net
effect of billions of people seeing that
content of millions of British young men
seeing that content is that over time it
will normalize those ideas there's
something called frequency biased by
psychology if we see something more
frequently we think it's normal and
acceptable and the net effect is
actually to put women at risk in the UK
and also radicalize our young men and
that is surely unacceptable
but these young men just to just to
stick with this point these young men
they have their own agency these men are
capable of making their own decisions
these men are capable of switching off
their PC their Mac their their iPhone
whatever and their other our other you
know male role models out there I mean
we can blame Andrew Tate for
disseminating this information but you
know there are plenty of Young Smart men
out there who are sitting down and
ingesting it consuming it by the bucket
load who frankly should know better
the problem with a platform like Tick
Tock is that it doesn't give you agency
over what you consume you are really
being driven by the algorithm let me
give you an example we set up a fake
account for a 16 year old boy on Tick
Tock now this is a platform that Andrew
takes really dominated within two
minutes a platform was recommending to
this clean brand new account under a
take videos and once we actually liked
one of those videos our for you so the
recommended videos Feed was flooded with
misogynistic homophobic and racist
content the problem is that there are
platforms that seek to to push this
into as many Feats as possible there's
not actually a supply demand
relationship in the way that would be
would say a newspaper where you get to
choose what you pick these are
algorithmically driven they're
mathematically driven platforms that
decide for you to a great extent what
you see and what you consume
whilst this content lingers on the web
the more we'll see it and potentially be
influenced by it you know even though
he's been banned on Tick Tock for some
time you know he's got various fan
accounts on Tick Tock that's still got
hundreds of thousands of followers so
even even though he's essentially been
de-platformed his content lives on that
Legacy still lives on Rachel Thompson is
a journalist specializing in Sex and
relationships and has long had Tate on
her radar but what I was seeing on on
those forums is essentially that men
think that the balance has sort of swung
too far the other way that we are
essentially living now in a feminist
Society where women have more privilege
than men and that that men are suffering
at the hands of feminism which they deem
a dangerous ideology I see some people
sort of taking offense at being called
you know like a white straight male and
to sort of you know to have that
uncomfortable conversation with once
self to examine one's own privilege I
think that um yeah this alternative
Viewpoint it's it can be quite
attractive I think given the fact that I
do not know I can hand on heart not name
a single man of my acquaintance who
looks at Andrew Tate and sees you know
an an image of masculinity that any of
us would ever want to to copy or to to
aspire to it's perhaps part of the
problem one actually identified by
people like Tate and and his ilk that
you know there are perhaps a lack of
male role models around at the moment
that there is something of a crisis in
in masculinity in terms of suicide in
terms of mental health generally in
terms of the widening education gap
between boys and girls I mean is that
perhaps part of this that they are
looking for someone to look up to they
go online when mum whoever else is
around isn't there and they they come
across someone who looks successful
looks like he's having a good time it
looks in essence you know in a number of
ways like what they would like to be
well I mean I think that's certainly it
could be the case I think that there's a
number of things going on like there is
absolutely a crisis happening within
masculinity
um but I think that what's lacking is
education around that I think that you
know we already have a crisis within sex
education for instance but I think we we
also could really do with and I actually
think this forms part of sex education
actually but
um examining the impact of gender roles
um and that's something that can be
really valuable you know if people who
are teachers people who are responsible
in terms of you know they are like
educated right in this topic and they
are not going to spread misinformation
uh when it comes to masculinity and they
can have a nuanced conversation with
young men
um then you know to examine those gender
roles to examine the impact that the
patriarchy that toxic masculinity has on
young men and you know on boys
um and adult men uh that those can be
really valuable conversations and
um can have a long lasting impact on not
just
boys and men's lives but also on
everyone's lives Andrew Tate it
certainly won't be the last and but he
also certainly wasn't the first I mean
you think of other people who occupied
kind of similar spaces online you know
Hunter Moore the most most hated man in
the internet yeah people may have seen
that documentary that that website that
Revenge that poorly named revenge porn
uh website that he set up so absent the
type of conversations that you were just
talking about between peers and and
young men take us through the real world
consequences or of the level of of this
level of misogyny being spread to such
an extent yeah I mean Andrew Tate is he
is absolutely part of a bigger problem
of not just online misogyny but also
misogyny and wider Society
um and unfortunately we are already
seeing his impact you know a tangible
impact in children
um and I saw a thread over the weekend
um about a child minder who was looking
after a little boy age 10 and his little
sister aged seven and the little boy had
been essentially indoctrinated already
by the ideas that Andrew Tate is
spreading basically said that he
believed that men were stronger than
girls and had his his behavior was
having an impact on the girls in his
school and his also his little sister
who who called him a bully he was
bullying the the girls at school and
it's just really alarming to hear about
that sort of stuff happening because you
know that's a real example of these
views which we see online them sort of
filtering out into the real world and
having having a dangerous impact on boys
and you know also I I saw her it's a now
deleted Reddit post from a female high
school teacher whose students of high
school age were citing Andrew Tate
refusing to do their homework and
stating that women women should only be
Housewives and so you know this is
obviously you know it's filtering out in
into the real world amongst children
amongst teenagers but in a broader
context we know from academic research
that misogyny is the root cause of
sexual violence and that you know the
consequences like we're literally
talking about life and death here we're
talking about sexual violence which is
you know something that affects a huge
proportion of women and marginalized
genders and girls and you know this is
this is where this comes from it's not
harmless it's not some sort of comedy
routine that I mean unfortunately it
does come up when it comes up on your
for you page on Tick Tock and people
respond to it and there's often you see
like it's done in a funny kind of
comical way like the responses to it and
I'm like but this is really serious
actually it's really dangerous and let's
bring Imran back in at this point I mean
Imran when you have content remaining up
on all of these platforms despite the
fact that the creator has been banned I
mean are we in a situation now where
this is just irreparate book that
there's nothing can be done you see part
of the reason that we can't we haven't
been able to fix it today is because we
don't have the tools we don't have
Believers to pull to change things so
what you do there is when you've got
these big problems being created by an
otherwise productive industry you create
regulation you essentially you shift the
costs of dealing with those harms from
society back to the company we did it
for example with tobacco with climate
change uh we've done it with with a
whole range of Industries and that's why
we need an online safety bill so the UK
has designed a bill which is actually
going through Parliament but has been
stalled because of this leadership
election that's been going on in the
conservative party which which would
start to shift some of those costs back
it says if you create considerable harm
you know you're creating that harm your
terms and conditions say that you won't
create those Harms we might actually
find you if you don't deal with them in
the way that you claim you will
maketh man well Andrew Tate might want
to take a long hard look in the mirror
but to dismiss his output as infantile
as the purile ramblings of an embittered
alpha would be to ignore just how
popular he is there remain thousands
perhaps millions of young men hungry for
this type of content and if Tate truly
did make millions from his misogyny it
can't be long before others follow in
his footsteps
Andrew Tate did not respond to Sky News
request for comment but speaking online
on Twitch on Friday he said this
a lot of things that have been taken and
chopped up and thrown online are things
from a very long time ago when I didn't
have a fraction of the influence I have
now I'm not apologizing for them I'm not
even saying they are intrinsically wrong
Tate continued
I've made countless videos about how
women need to be protected how women
need to be respected how important the
women are in my life how much I respect
my mother I've done loads of things
positive about women we've also been
hearing from YouTube in a statement to
Bloomberg it said that channels
associated with Andrew Tate had been
removed because of multiple violations
of its Community guidelines and terms of
service including its hate speech policy
if a channel is terminated the uploader
is unable to use own or create any other
YouTube channels meanwhile Tick Tock
said in a statement misogyny is a
hateful ideology that is not tolerated
on tick tock
my thanks to Shanti Das Imran Amit
Rachel Thompson and of course to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily hosted
by me Neil Patterson this Edition was
produced and mixed by Emery Woodhouse
the dealy's editor is Phillip